et ce n'est pas parce que nous serons
moins nombreux à table qu'il ne faudra
pas se faire plaisir
bonjour et le nord vous allez nous
raconter votre rencontre avec un chef
pâtissier exactement noël approche à
grands pas vous l'avez dit du coup nous
sommes allés à la rencontre du chef
nicolas hâle irwin chef pâtissier
évidemment qui tient l'atelier gâteau à
guyancourt avec nicolas landry il nous
présente sa recette de tarte vanille
noix de pécan qu'il a revisité comme du
ch on retrouve en fait tous les éléments
forts de la tarte
on a créé cette année mais déclinées en
au but voilà donc en fait on a un
biscuits imbibés dans un bus à la
vanille d'ailleurs très vallier vanille
bourbon de madagascar avec une crème
panna cotta c'est une sorte de panacotta
allégé comme une gentille et un coeur
coulant de praliné praliné à la noix de
pécan textures et les verts et du
travail et maintenant que nous avons
l'eau à la bouche comment se réalise
cette bûche et ben c'est ib le chef la
bo de l'atelier gâteau qui va nous
l'expliquer on va commencer par un vive
et de biscuits donc sur cette étape loeb
faut être généreux mais il faut pas
détrempé le biscuit ceux ci ont des 30
le biscuit on aura du mal à rouler
[Musique]
où
après avoir un bébé le biscuit donc il
faut cocher la panna cotta à la vanille
sur le biscuit ce potage donc
ah oui d'abord si on ne sait pas faire
de panna cotta on peut bien sûr pas
d'inquiétude on peut bien sûr le
remplacer par de la chantilly ou bien du
mascarpone et donc le chef nous
conseille d'utiliser une poche à douille
qui se nomme chemin de fer pour ceux qui
connaissent mais si on n'a pas ça à la
maison pas d'inquiétude non plus on peut
utiliser une grande cuillère
il faut laisser une petite bande l'ip
toutefois à la fin pour sur le biscuit
et on passe à l'étape notre paix quand
exactement origine j'ai bien suivi la
recette c'est ça on va pouvoir passer
aux pécan up qui vont apporter le
croustillant et une légère amertume
parce que la paix quand c'est légèrement
à merde là on dispose comme on veut le
tout c'est d'être régulier pour que la
personne qui mange la bouche de ce côté
là où de ce côté là est plus ou moins la
même sensation après avoir disposé les
noix de pécan on passe ensuite à la
dernière étape juste avant le roulage de
la biche
le chef insère le praliné paix quand
donc ces de la crème et du praliné
mélanger et ce mélange doit apporter le
sucre et l'onctuosité et le coeur
coulant ce coeur coulant c'est la petite
surprise dans l'anus et qu'il faut
maintenant rouler non il va l'étape
cruciale on va rouler la bûche l'appui
on a travaillé sur des bus qui sont
roulés donc pour avoir un côté
traditionnel et sûr des goûts qui sont
pas du tout traditionnel up
donc on est vraiment sur un aspect de
buchrain over mais avec tout notre
savoir faire est tout neuf en tout notre
gourmandise
voilà bus est maintenant terminée on
peut la décorer un peu comme on le
souhaite le chef lui il a entouré d'un
glaçage au chocolat blanc avec quelques
décors supplémentaire pour un peu de
croustillant et puis là parsemé d'éclats
de noix de pécan inapte il n'y a plus
qu'à se régaler wilfried salaire assez
facile mais si on n'est pas très doué
tout de même pour la pâtisserie un site
internet on peut commander
on peut aller commander en ligne et la
commande est justement chez chef
nicholas lewin atelier gâteau gâteau
avec un haut point comme voilà pour le
site internet merci eléonore même si
vous n'avez pas ramené cette bûche en
plateau et non